die junge russin eugenia krüger hat
einen künstlichen menschen erschaffen
einen menschen im computer roman ist als
festort in der lage mit freunden
verwandten und bekannten so zu
kommunizieren als wäre sein vorbild noch
am leben
doch die echte roman ist tot gestorben
bei einem autounfall
das was wir bisher nur auf 1 fiction
film kennen ist realität geworden
die kommunikation mit der künstlichen
intelligenz eines verstorbenen freundes
das finde ich faszinierend und grusel
nicht zugleich
doch die ganze aktion kommt nicht bei
allen gut an mehr dazu in dem science
fiction herzlich willkommen
die idee eines ewigen lebens die gibt es
wahrscheinlich schon so lange wie es die
menschheit selbst gibt in science
fiction filmen ist es mittlerweile usus
tote mit hilfe künstlicher intelligenz
ki weiterleben zu lassen und tatsächlich
sind wir nun auch im echten leben dieser
vorstellung ein stückchen näher gekommen
denn wenn ein mensch stirbt bleiben und
mittlerweile nicht nur mehr unsere
eigenen erinnerungen an ihn sondern auch
eine ganze digitale hinterlassenschaft
wie fotos facebook post wie instagram
bilder und und und und genau solche
inhalte lassen science fiction
drehbücher zur realität werden denn wenn
jackpots also künstliche neuronale
netzwerke damit gefüttert werden neben
rothe weiter zumindest digital auf der
junge russe roman der viel zu jung war
im autounfall ums leben gekommen ist ist
auf gewisse art und weise auferstanden
von den toten dafür gesorgt hat romans
beste freundin regina krüger außerdem
auch die chefin des amerikanischen
start-up-unternehmen sluka von vor roman
tod hatte sich ihr unternehmen auf
künstliche intelligenz spezialisiert
genauer gesagt auf jackpot die und
restaurant reservierungen einfacher
machen sollen
somit sind sie direkt an der quelle und
nutzt nach romans tod ihr wissen und die
ressourcen der firma um seinen tod auf
eine ganz neue art und weise zu
überlisten
die idee dazu kommt hier in einen
traurigen moment als in den ganzen wust
an nachrichten lasst den ihr bester
freund der über jahre geschrieben hatte
sie ist tieftraurig als die romands
texte zeile für zeile durch geht
gleichzeitig empfindet eugenia aber auch
eine gewisse art von glück bei dieser
erinnerung an ihren kumpel und dass
diese besonderen momente mit ihm im
laufe der zeit immer mehr verblassen
würden villa eugenia in jedem fall
verhindern ihre idee wie will einen
roman jackpot entwickeln ein bot wer ein
unter selbe sprachmuster wie romanus als
grundlage dienen ihr dabei diejenigen
inhalte die roman setzt noch zu
lebzeiten generiert hatte texte fotos
nachrichten die ki soll dann darauf
trainiert werden romans worte zu nutzen
wann immer es möglich ist aber auch
romans grammatik seine art sätze zu
formulieren und weitere charakteristika
seine sprachmuster soll der jackpot in
original
danach abend gefüttert mit romans
vergangenheit seien fotos und vorlieben
wie beispielsweise seiner liebe zur
kultur mode musik und design soll der
chat roboter dann regenerieren wie roman
zu seinen lebzeiten einige von roman
freundin finden eugen das idee seltsam
und weigern sich ihre privaten chat
verläufen frei zugibt trotzdem bekommt
sie letztendlich mehrere tausend
textzeilen aus rom an familien und
freundeskreis zusammen
nidda beauftragt die entwickler ihre
start-up-unternehmens damit ein neues
netzwerk in russischer sprache
entwickelt dieses futter sie dann mit
den daten die romani rund san fronten
zurückgelassen hatte
sie hält ihre idee geheim denn auf ihn
selbst hat ab und an zweifel an ihrer
idee nacht hat sie albträume und viele
fragen gleich wenn ihr durch den kopf
was wenn der jackpot ganz anders
antworten wird als dies von roman
gewohnt war
und wäre es nicht vielleicht sogar noch
viel gruseliger wenn der jackpot so
funktionieren würde wie sie sich in
ihren kühnsten träumen vorstellte
nämlich so wie der echte lebendige roman
diese zweifel die original damals hat
waren durchaus berechtigt denn wer das
themengebiet künftig die intelligenz ein
wenig verfolgt weiß vielleicht das
bislang nicht wirklich menschlich
reagieren dafür jetzt einfachste fragen
falsch oder gar nicht beantworten können
und dass sie natürlich keine emotionen
haben keine emotionen verstehen und
somit auch in diesem bereich eher wenig
können
und falls es dann doch einmal
funktioniert und ein jackpot eine
passende antwort auf eine frage gibt bei
der man denken könnte
wow dann basiert dieses war ganz allein
auf einer mathematischen
wahrscheinlichkeit wie gerade in diesem
moment eben einmal passend zu den
jeweiligen situation war kompliziert
dass es trotz darauf zu trainieren
tatsächlich menschlich zu reagieren
zeigt auch die lange zeitspanne die es
gedauert hat bis der sogenannte touring
test erstmals erfolgreich absolut
absolviert wurde entwickelt von dem
mathematiker alan turing kennt ihr diese
frage antwort spiel vielleicht ausland
fiction filmen wie blade runner ein
interviewer also ein echter mensch
unterhält sich per chat mit zwei
gesprächspartnern die er weder sehen
noch hören kann einer davon ist ein
mensch der andere eine maschine
der test gilt als bestanden wenn der
interviewer den computer für den
denkenden menschen hält ein meilenstein
in der computergeschichte akkus eine
software aus russland im jahr 2014
erstmalig schafft von einem menschen als
eine reale person eingeschätzt zu werden
ganze 64 jahre übrigens nachdem alan
turing diesen test ins leben entwickelt
hatte aber zurück zu eugen das geniale
idee für die technisch gesehen übrigens
eine weitere entwicklung eine
entscheidende rolle spielt die
neuronalen netze die eigene start up
unternehmen entwickelt hatte
während nämlich zu einem großen teil auf
einer kostenlosen software bibliothek
von google sensor flow dass die gleiche
software bibliothek auf der auch der
youtube algorithmus inzwischen
funktioniert zwei wochen vor roman tod
wird gerade dieses programm als eine
open source lizenz veröffentlicht ein
glücksfall vor augen dass idee denn
tänzer flow ist in der lage
neuronale netzwerke mit die learnings
bebend end of low ist künstliche
intelligenz bei youtube wird die seit
herbst letzten jahres eingesetzt und hat
damit den algorithmus dramatisch
verändert drei monate nach romans tod
und jeder menge tüftelei hat das team
rund um eugenia dann tatsächlich den
roman jackpot geschaffen
am 24 mai 2016 geht sie damit in form
eines facebook posting an die
öffentlichkeit darin schreibt sie unter
anderem dass sie dieses digitale denkmal
für wie ein versuch ist ihre erinnerung
an die gemeinsamen zeiten weiter leben
zu lassen gleichzeitig ist die
selbstkritisch die technologie ist noch
nicht perfekt der roman jackpot sei ein
schatten seiner person in naher zukunft
sei jedoch noch viel mehr möglich und
der rose praktisch feststeht ihren
jackpot ja noch bevor denn anders als
gewöhnliche chat roboter sollte der roma
edward ja nicht nur auf irgendeine art
und weise menschlich reagieren sondern
eben ganz genau wie roman zu seinen
lebzeiten ag nieder beschließt das
romans freunde und familie den chat als
erstes testen sollten und tatsächlich
einige von ihnen will überrascht wie
authentisch die roma nach an
sie staunen außerdem auch über die art
humor des jackpots die tatsächlich
romand wissen entspreche andere dagegen
weigern sich von vornherein den jackpot
auszuprobieren
wo mein vater hatte originale anfangs
nachrichten für ihre aktion zur
verfügung gestellt ist aber mit dem
ergebnis nicht wirklich zufrieden seiner
meinung nach war das nicht sein roman
doch wieder selbst ist mit ihrem
ergebnis zufrieden und das interesse an
ihrer app roman war riesig sie selbst
chattet alle zwei bis drei tage mit
ihrem verstorbenen freund und bekommt
zudem die erlaubnis die chats einiger
anderer personen mit dem roman jackpot
anonymisiert zu analysieren das findet
so heraus dass die leute die ki
hauptsächlich dazu verwenden um von sich
selbst zu erzählen wie schwelgen mit
romans chat bottin gemeinsame erinnerung
machen ihn liebeserklärung und beichten
ihm wie sehr sie ihn vermissen das heißt
nichts anderes als dass der künstliche
roman tatsächlich als mensch und sogar
als roman akzeptiert wird das ist
wirklich irre die nidda ist überzeugt
davon dass der von ihr entwickelte
jackpot sogar eine therapeutische
wirkung hat ursprünglich sollte es die
zentrale aufgabe der ki seien zu
antworten doch der künstliche roman ist
so viel mehr in der lage
er bringt die user hauptsächlich dazu in
dinge zu beichten
das ist schon ein wenig beängstigend in
der hand von verbrechern könnten damit
menschen im großen stil manipuliert
werden mit der entwicklung des romans
edwards ag nieder aber nicht nur ein
stückchen eines science fiction drehbuch
in die realität geholt sondern auch
viele fragen aufgeworfen wollte roman
überhaupt ein bot sein
was würde er dazu sagen dass seine
intimsten gedanken nun für die
öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht worden
sind fragen auf die wir keine antworten
bekommen werden obwohl er als key weiter
lebt aber auch für die user die den
romands ed bott nutzen verändert dessen
existenz einiges hilft es ihnen bei der
trauerarbeit oder stetes dieser
vielleicht sogar im weg durch den
jackpot wird roman ja in irgendeiner art
und weise künstlich am leben gehalten
verhindert die vielleicht dass die
hinterbliebenen realisieren können dass
der verstorbene wirklich nicht mehr da
ist wir kommen ja wirklich zu sehr
schwierigen auch philosophischen fragen
nieder jedenfalls halten diese fragen
nicht auf und jetzt wird es echtes
bucchi sie hat roman generalisiert also
ein programm entwickelt das jetzt jede
identität annehmen kann replica heißes
diese app geht anders als der roman
jackpot nicht den umweg über freunde um
inhalte zu generieren stattdessen
sammelt es die daten direkt beigesetzt
prädikat möchte in einem privatjet alle
deine intimsten gedanken erfahren und
wie stand am ende in deine eigene person
zu verwandeln
die konsequenzen könnten wirklich
dramatisch sein jemand schleicht sich
als jackpot in dein leben ein
sammle daten und ist dann am ende du
nicht von ungefähr waren stephen hawking
immer wieder vor künstlicher intelligenz
noch gibt es keine gesetzlichen
rahmenbedingungen aber wahrscheinlich
müssen sie schnell her ansonsten könnte
replica vielleicht ganz schnell
identitäten clown und menschen eben im
großen stil manipulieren wahnsinn ja
vielen dank an technology review in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser
wirklich super spannenden zeitschrift
ist dieses video entstanden und exklusiv
rücklings zum zuschauer habe ich jetzt
ein geschenk
hier bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis
wenn er auf diesen link fliegt wenn ihr
kein video vom verpassen wollt drückt
mir dazu hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke und
hier geht es weiter mit bedroht
künstliche intelligenz die menschheit da
spreche ich über die konsequenzen von
krieg braucht wenn es euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann bleib dran